The story in the story of Adam and Eve
is a Meta story and it's a story for two
reasons.
One is it's about how stories transform
because Adam and Eve are in this
unconscious paradise and then it
collapses and that happens to every
potential story,
right?
That's niches realization.
He said,
look,
imagine that you live within a belief
system and then something arises to
challenge the belief system.
Not only does the belief system
collapse,
but something worse happens.
Your belief in belief systems collapses,
and that's the road tonight.
Now it doesn't have to because you can
jump from one belief system to another,
but sometimes that doesn't work is that
you do a medic critique and you say,
oh,
I was living in this protective
structure and it turned out to be
flawed.
Okay?
One alternative is jumped to another
protective structure.
Fine.
Another alternative is protective
structures that themselves are not to be
trusted.
Bang,
you're in chaos.
How the hell are you going to get out of
that?
That's the pathway.
Denialism.
While you can,
you can.
You can work your way through that.
That's difficult,
or you can do what young would regard as
a soul damaging move and you can
sacrifice your new knowledge and re
identify with something real rigid and
restricted,
which is what I would say is happening
to some degree with the people in or
Europe who are turning to a regressive
nationalism as an alternative to to the
current state of chaos.
It's like I know that that people need
to identify with local groups.
I understand that,
but they risk the danger of making the
state the ultimate God and that's order,
but that's not a good replacement for
chaos.
It's just another kind of catastrophe.
Right?
Too much order.
Too much chaos,
both.
Catastrophes.
You want to stand in the middle somehow
and mediate between the two and that's
where you have your real strength
because then it isn't that you've
discovered a safe place because even the
bloody right wingers or after a safe
place,
right?
They just want it to be the state.
Yeah,
exactly.
Well,
there's no safe places and the next
issue is do you really want a safe
place?
Is that what you want?
You want to be so weak that you want to
be protected from threat.
What the hell kind of life is that?
You're a paralyzed rabbit in a hole
that's no life for a human being.
You should be confronting danger and the
unknown and mlevel.
It's because,
and the reason for that too is this is
the weird paradox.
This is,
and I believe this is the paradox,
first of all,
that was discovered in part by Buddha,
but also laid forth very clearly in
Christianity,
which is that the PA,
the solution to the problem of tragedy
and malevolence is the willingness to
face the who the hell would ever guess
that.
It's completely paradoxical.
It's a completely paradoxical
suggestion,
is that,
well,
why does it work well?
Because the more you confront the two of
them,
the more you grow and maybe you can grow
so that you're actually larger than the
chaos and malevolence itself and you
think,
well,
what's the evidence for that?
And that's easy.
That's what people do.
That is how we learn.
Like every time you expose your child to
something new,
a playground,
what are they exposed to?
Chaos and malevolence now there's more
to it than that obviously because kids
play and they,
you know,
they promote each other and they form
friendships and all of that,
but in the playground itself,
there is the complexity of the social
structure and the malevolence of the
bully.
It's right there and the q throw your
kid in there and you say adapt,
and they do.
Okay,
so they can do it at a small scale.
It's not trivial,
but the playground is a complicated
place.
The kid can adapt.
Well,
how much can you scale that up?
Can you scale that up to from the chaos
and order and malevolence of the
playground to chaos and order and
malevolence itself?
Well,
that's the question.
I don't think there's any reason to
answer that in the negative,
so because we don't know the full extent
of the human being and it is the problem
that's worked out.
So in the Buddhist story,
for example,
what happens after,
so Buddha's world collapses in the same
way that Adam and Eve's world collapses,
it's a consequence of repetitive
exposure to mortality and death.
What happens to Buddha's?
He realizes that the little protected
city that his father made for him,
the walled garden,
it's exactly the same motif that's in
this Adam and Eve story is,
is it's.
It's what it's.
It's fatally flawed.
That kind of protection cannot exist and
he discovered that in pieces,
right?
Which is exactly what happens to
children is that they go out,
they discover a limit.
They run back and the parents can help
them with the limit.
They run out,
they discover limit.
They run back,
but some at some point they run out,
they discover a limit.
They run back and the parents have
nothing to say to them because they've
hit the same limit that the parents hit.
Just like,
well,
what are you gonna do with your life?
How are you going to.
How are you going to operate in this
archetipal universe?
While your parents can only say,
well,
they can say you identify with the
proper archetypal figures they do that.
They at least act that out for you,
but at some point it's a problem that
they cannot solve for you without making
you weaker.
That's the thing,
you know,
so it's an interesting thing that I've
learned in therapy because one of the
things you have to learn as a therapist
is how do you not take your client's
problems home with you,
so very common existential problem that
beginning therapists face because
they're afraid.
It's like while you're dealing with
people all the time who have serious
problems,
sometimes it's mental illness,
although less frequently than you think
and sometimes it's just that they're
having a good catastrophe right there.
Their parents have cancer or something
like that,
or their father has Alzheimer's and
they're unemployed.
They have a drug problem or they have a
schizophrenia zonar like these aren't
mental illness problems,
right?
Those are just catastrophes.
And so people are discussing those with
you all the time.
How do you avoid being crushed by that
or avoid taking it home?
And the answer to that is you don't
steal the problem that that's the
answer.
It's like you have some problems.
If you come and talk to me,
I'll help you figure out how to solve
them.
I will not tell you how to solve.
I won't steal your problems because what
we're trying to do in therapy is number
one,
so your problem number two,
turn you into a great solver of problems
and the second one is way more important
than the first one,
and so you never solve someone's problem
by removing from them the opportunity to
solve their problem.
That's theft.
That's the eatables situation.
That's the over protective mother.
No father can play that role too.
We're talking about architectural
representations.
It's like all protect you at the cost of
your ability to protect yourself.
No wrong.
That's that.
That's a sin.
That's a good way of thinking about it.
That is not what you do with people,
not with your children,
not with your partner,
not with yourself.
You don't do that.
That destroys people's adaptive
competence and it and it disarms them in
the face of chaos and malevolence and
that's a terrible,
you know,
send someone out are unarmed in a world
like that,
it's a terrible thing to do so.
And if people aren't strong enough to
manage it,
then they get resentful and then when
you get the downhill spiral that goes
along with that.
Okay,
so the Med is story is partly you're in
a mat,
you're,
you have a map,
but it's insufficient and things will
come up to disrupt it.
And sometimes the disruption is
catastrophic.
Everything falls apart.
That's what happens to the Buddha.
And that's what happens to Adam and eve
and the rest of the biblical stories are
actually an attempt to put that back
together.
Now that that's been assembled,
as I said,
it's been assembled over centuries.
Right?
Okay.
We've got the problem.
The problem is the apocalypse,
the ever present reality of the
apocalyptic fall,
that's the problem.
And so you could say,
well what is that?
It's the insufficiency of all potential
conceptual schemes,
right?
Your conceptual schemes are insufficient
to deal with the complexity of the
world.
It's a permanent problem.
So what do you do?
You stop relying on your conceptual
schemes.
That's part of the answer.
You start relying on your instead on
your ability to actively generate
conceptual schemes in the face of chaos.
And malevolence and so that makes you
someone that identifies with your
creative capacity,
your creative,
courageous capacity for articulation and
action in the face of the unknown rather
than some formulaic approach to the
territory and that is not.
And that the idea is that that elevates
your character to the point where you
can withstand tragedy and malevolence
without becoming corrupt and that
provides a permanent solution to the
problem.
Well then you might say,
cynically,
what's your evidence that that's a
permanent solution and answer that is
while the evidence isn't all in yet,
first of all,
because people only live that way
partially and so we haven't put the
hypothesis to the full test and second,
we don't know what our limitations are.
We have no idea what our limitations are
and they're,
they're both greater and lesser than we
imagined because you know,
you have to ask yourself like if people
stopped adding voluntarily to the misery
of the world and devoted themselves to
setting things straight,
setting themselves straight and setting
the things around them straight,
what would happen?
And the answer to that is,
well,
there'd be a hell of a lot less
unnecessary misery in the world,
so that might not be a bad place to
start.
But apart from that,
there's very little that we can say,
could we overcome the catastrophe of
mortality?
Why not?
You think that's beyond our capacity?
Could we make the world a place where no
one was suffering any more than
necessary and still allow the world to
exist?
Well,
possibly because we don't know the
limitations of our capacity.
We're only running at 40 percent if
that.
I would say if we don't make full use of
all the people that are in the world,
we don't have our situation set up so
that the gifts that they could offer to
everyone are fully realized.
We haven't set the systems up for that
yet.
So we waste people like mad and then we
waste ourselves like mad.